I'm a man on a mission I want to take
away fear there's a lot of unnecessary
suffering going on just because people
believe the wrong things it's destiny
and it is fade fade and if destiny and
all that no this time we learn to
control our happiness health and
strength need motivation watch the top
10 with believe nation what's that
believe nation it's seven my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have Michael Jordan level talent at
something and I want you to find it
embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's get your motivation
to attend and get you believing in you
grab a snack and chew in today's lessons
from a man who want from growing up in
the Netherlands and being attracted to
the cold since age 17 to now holding 26
world records including climbing to the
top of Mount Everest and nothing but
shorts and shoes his wim HOF and here's
my take on his top ten rules of success
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one take control of your life what was
your life like before you became the
Iceman and actually I was a father of
four kids and bringing them up alone
because my wife accidentally the 95 so
that kind of like adversity and sadness
maybe motivated you to oh yeah inspire
self and in the same way a lot of people
who do yes deep trigger where I got
peace was in these breathing exercises
swimming outside in the cold the coldest
merciless but righteous as well all the
people say you know that you cannot
steer a life or you cannot do this and
yeah it's part of life and it's destiny
and it is fate fate and if destiny and
all that no this time we learn to
control our happiness health and
strength and that's not philosophical or
sectarian it's chemistry rule number two
don't let fear stop you was there ever a
time in your life where you lost belief
in yourself
whoa that many times I've encountered
almost you know death and then I'm
losing it how do you come back from that
tougher experience yes yes how do you
retrain your your body in your mind is
believe in the next record the next
adventure yeah actually very quick an
example for example is the first time I
had to do a record with the Guinness
World Records swimming under the guys
say 50 meters one hole here 100 there
one meter of ice and then breath-hold
freezing waters beyond the Polar Circle
situation and at the day before I had to
do the actual record and went in I had
no goggles on I lost away because I lost
a sight
got frozen the cornea the retina and I
lost it I did hundred and thirteen
meters you couldn't find the hole and I
couldn't find it all my gosh I almost no
I in the end I fainted it but I did not
feel any agony and I felt actually quite
peaceful after minutes and minutes are
under the eye swimming you exhaust your
body and I got is this narrowed vision
boom just seeing that that's
physiological Wow and then I went down
swimming it was all okay was like I was
swimming into the death unconsciousness
and that somebody grabbed me a diver and
he brought me back to the 50-meter Oh
which are you kept going past the hole
yeah yeah yeah completely off and then
it was the rehearsal so the diver was
are not underneath the ice he was still
up there but hey I was or four minutes
too much too long then they woke me
under the ice wow that's a moment so I
come back from the how do you train your
mind to believe in yourself again at
that moment I actually had 100 i io verk
aim the the fear of death and die there
was no agony that's strange
and that's past my perception of what I
thought it was death you know fear and
there's nobody wants to die is there
maybe it's much more beautiful out there
huh we're in the afterlife and now we
got a live eye ah to die I'm afraid not
to live you know quotes and things but
based on experience and so I really
defied death and the fearful death over
there not defying like I did it know
what happened and I learned from it to
take away my fear for death so and then
the other day I only had to do 50 meters
which was a Baltic a couple butterfly
kicks and you're there huh
that's it came out happy yeah yeah okay
that was my number one I liked it wreck
it do you face fear now when you go into
some extreme challenge or in any part of
your life good question any part of
their life because it's all about the
life and actually no Miami man on a
mission no fears no no no I'm a man on a
mission I want to take away fear you
know irrational fears traumatic fears
fears created because you do not handle
mental issues
nice grief emotion PTSD trauma
depression those things we are going to
tackle and somebody's got to do this and
I should have no fear to accomplish that
you know a man on a mission should not
think in fear you should go and
accomplish his mission yeah and be
focused so there I am I feel feel like
everybody because it's natural to mm-hm
you feel fear failures or you said don't
know I fear I feel you fear like
everybody but it doesn't hold you back
from moving for not come on man it's a
much too important rule number three my
personal favorite embrace the power of
the mind
explain the mission why are you doing
this why it's so important to you it's
not just about setting the world record
why do you do this yes as I said and a
lot of stuff outside in nature because I
felt this disconnection from nature
inside from the soul itself soul is not
able to express and you can see it in
the world full of depression and
autoimmune diseases cancer there are all
those things and anxiety so nobody knows
actually is because of the disconnection
of nature so resulted in me in an
awkward feeling I don't know what there
is but there is more than meets the eye
I'm going into a soul search and that
brought me
to all kinds of traditions as a tarik
disciplines languages religions debates
about philosophies cultures anything you
know but in the end it didn't connect
with me that's what the cold water came
in I had a cold water is merciless but
righteous okay so mum and you gotta be
there right but little by little you
begin to wake up to that what you feel
inside it's beginning to wake up a real
primordial this connection is beginning
to connect to your consciousness
brain-body connection and now after
doing 26 of those world records about
numerous war challenges got me gotten
encountered with scientists and then it
came about that I was awakening and
stimulating and influencing systems
within the body they thought of not
being able to be influenced or connected
with for humans they thought that humans
cannot happen
it's an autonomic nervous system but
it's an autonomy care process outside of
our world but brain body can actually
remember connection and there it is and
now I'm able to connect enter and make
the difference and that's what I did in
the studies Wims mission is to use his
body as a laboratory to revolutionize
our understanding of physiology in 2011
he was injected with the bacterial
endotoxin in an experiment that
challenged our understanding of the
nervous system in normal humans the
injection should cause a strong immune
response leading to fever chills and
headaches
but not and when it appeared that he was
somehow able to suppress his immune
response by making his body secreted
Rennell in' suggesting that his method
can allow us to influence our immune
system at will scientists thought he
might just be a freak of nature so to
further prove this theory they performed
the same experiment on 12 subjects women
trained in Poland and the same thing
happened
Rufio only got after competitive study
with groups so I took on a full group I
trained him for days to get into the
autonomic nervous system and all those
things and they got air administered
with the bacteria and as well all within
a quarter of our entering in the into
those systems and now we're getting
somewhere
power of the mind yeah we're dealing in
modern day society we can go to the moon
we can go to Mars and everywhere but we
cannot tap into the depth of ourselves
and make the difference or even
depression anxiety fear trauma PTSD
anything rule number four live in
harmony with nature I think there is a
global tendency now which is looking for
answers which is looking for new things
today it's a it's a like a general way
of thinking that the past did not is not
going to make it for the present
situation we have too much stress too
much autoimmune diseases cancer
depression we are not happy anymore we
cannot guarantee this happiness strength
and health to our children what's
happening with the love so yeah that
love within the native people they live
much more in in harmony with nature and
we thought as Westerners to take them
over colonize them and all that but now
we are looking at the dead and we
actually need to go back to
become in harmony with nature doesn't
mean we go or live in teepees and
wigwams and caves and all that we got
these big buildings that's Hedra but
don't forget if we are able to shoot to
the moon and not to become happy strong
and healthy then we got some place to
visit rule number five find your passion
tell us about the first time he decided
to jump into an ice-cold pool yeah I was
17 I also began just because I felt this
urge within myself there is more between
Avenue and earth I didn't know what but
I was driven to find out that's the way
it all starts with the intuition with an
instinct something inexplicable drives
me so before I when I was 12 years I was
already into psychology books and I was
the into karate and yoga and all those
things anything I could help I get my
hands upon I was doing it so at 17 I was
really like a ripe fruit to get into the
depth and that's what what happened when
I some day morning I was outside as so
thin layer of ice under water I looked
around because I had to undress myself
and nobody around Sunday morning easy
like Sunday no go into the water and I
felt from the inside this is it
you you feel it and only one minute and
it gave me a rush and so the other day I
came back to see if it was repeated and
yes and you know what happens in the
beginning I was really bad I did not
really feel the cold I became aware I
didn't feel the cold that was like it
was playing around with their with their
eyes that was the first very remarkable
thing to me it's not cold that is
actually in a natural incapacity of ours
to deal the of the body to be able
to deal with environment the impact is
there so from there I started became
aware that if I began to breathe like
this deeper
oh my body got charged and I don't
recommend this for anybody but I was
doing breathing exercises in the water
at ease and at a certain moment it just
a couple of monster took I could stay
for five to seven minutes under the ice
every day no problem very controlled
don't do it if he cannot control this
yeah yeah I learn gradually to learn to
ox energize the body so much in harsh
environment that you become so tranquil
like a baby in the room under their eyes
wonderful deep meditation and that's
what I did every day rule number six
change your chemistry if we just breathe
more deeply change the chemistry inside
not shallow breathing deep breathing
slowly but surely this is what you do
consciously can you do this 30 times the
chemistry in the body in the tissue is
changing and it's changing so that the
body is becoming Oxana just alkaline and
then suddenly the brain-body connection
is possible by pressurizing by
[Music]
once you begin to have that connection
with the body then you are able to
connect within in the brain and that's
what we do right now with Stanford
University to get rid of PTSD fear
trauma and depression to learn to expand
consciousness and together with
breathing you create the right chemistry
and then the neurons they channel up and
thus your perception your consciousness
is gonna be you smell more you see their
colors brighter you experience deeper
and that's the brain and then connecting
once again with all the cells makes you
a beautiful living being rule number
seven learned by trial and error what
does it take in the brain what kind of
control does it take from the brain the
mind over the body to go into extremes
as I have been shown like you going
climbing Mount Everest to the Death Zone
in shorts or yeah going to record
distances under the ice or standing for
two hours in eyes directly contact what
kind of mind control do you need to be
able to do that that's what I learnt to
do through trial and error just by
following my feeling so I felt good and
good if good feeling is like connection
connection of are of the mind over the
body that feels good that actually is a
way to learn to bring up your psyche
controlled and that is what is needed in
a very extreme situation where an
ice-water is taking place but actually I
took the ice water environment to learn
to deal with my mind in connection with
the body rule number eight step out of
your comfort zone we've been saying now
to 5,000,000 Spartans out there get out
of your comfort zone get uncomfortable
if the weather is bad go outside do a
workout in the bad weather yeah right
we're saying to the children get
uncomfortable and so we're not we're not
crazy
actually you
and get into real comfort because the
real comfort is being activated through
the natural elements first you get
through this little shivering of
outsiders but then at a certain moment
it begins to adapt from the deep inside
begins to adapt to the environment the
environmental stress and you feel alive
alive
you see rule number nine breathe and
believe there's a lot of unnecessary
suffering going on just because people
believe the wrong things they believe in
pills we believe in medicines they
believe depression cannot be tackled
they believe you cannot enter into your
brain and I tell you we found a way to
get back to yourself but get back to
mother nature within us and make some
sense within yourself you are the one
who is able now to make yourself happy
strong and healthy and that is entering
in all those systems just by by your
mind your we we are showing this through
science but do you need science when I
already show this in science with data
scientific results brain scans no
speculation I tell you but it takes time
for publishing and and to get it into
books and to get it in mainstream I tell
you here and right now
if youtubes believe and and breathe and
take a cold shower for God's sake
because it's good for your blood system
then you will become in their ability to
realign with the control within yourself
to become happy strong and healthy too
to control your mood and your energy
management and all look at other wise up
because it is simple very effective it's
here right now so my message to yours
just breathe and believe and rule number
ten the last one before a very special
bonus clip is do amazing things my
companion and my great friend a warrior
side of me able to overcome any
challenge is a big God no it's the
breath yeah I take it breathe with me
let it go Julio
imagine you are in the ice follow him
there you go let it go I keep him hold
up and there we go you can swim with me
under the water there you go it there he
goes crazy there he goes but he's doing
it he's not thinking if sphere look at
him go
[Music]
man where's the light there it is
ok ok
there we are yes
now I've got two really special bonus
wim hof clips on how to master your body
in mind and do the wim HOF method but
before that I want to make sure we are
moving from just watching a video to
actually taking action so I have three
questions homework for you to think
about as you watch this video question
number one what are you afraid of doing
and why must you conquer it question
number two what's the biggest lesson
that you have learned through trial and
error and question number three what's
the biggest area of your life or
business that you need to take control
of write it down for yourself do the
questions with a friend or leave the
answers down in the comments below
either way I want you moving from not
just watch another video but to actually
taking some kind of action in your
business or in your life thank you guys
so much for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon and enjoy the bonus
clip
well the Greeks used to say it's mind
and body right it's not yes right and
what drives me crazy is them there's so
many successful monetarily successful
people out there businesspeople that
have clearly mastered that or mastered
anything that requires the brain but
they're not taking care of their body
right can you imagine how much more
powerful they'd be if it was connected
oh yeah right
you know people who think they can
control it all it's just the surface of
the brain the deeper parts include the
sensation and experience with your body
then the brainstem is gonna work the
limbic system is going to work and when
they all come together there you got
expanding consciousness spirituality and
you can become very very powerful I
created a method the components are
breathing mindset and coal exposure
gradual non-forest called exposure and
that's to optimize the mind-body
connection wim has figured out ways
namely through breath work and through
exposure to cold to take conscious
control over aspects of his physiology
that for most people they simply can't
tune into in control
[Music]
the cold my warm friend it brings about
a whole lot of more energy and that were
together with breathing makes you so
powerful but then you lose your wife and
a toll rumbles down for children art
worth for my wife and there was to be
with her forever she was the love of my
life she died she suicided
it's a it's a black hole within yourself
it breaks your heart and you don't know
why but the Train of a daily life is
going on and you gotta catch up
otherwise you lose it so I had to be
there for my children and yes we created
a new nest my children made me survive
in that time but nature yield my words
the coal gave me a direct understanding
of deeper breathing and how to heal a
broken heart then I went did all kinds
of remarkable challenges apparently they
found it the very remarkable and great
and spectacular so came in contact with
television one after the other they
challenged me more more more more more
they go swim 50 meters are under the ice
go a swim hundred meters under the earth
flat mount everest ensures that ladder
up that the scientists became curious
hey what this man is doing is not
possible physiologically
the science of what wim HOF method does
is one of the primary interests of my
lab now because it is so powerful and
spin shown to be powerful in the immune
system we believe it will also hold some
real potential for treatment of
neurologic diseases and this breathing
technique brings you right into the
deepest part of our physiology anybody
can do it so you become the alchemist of
your own chemistry altruistic world
domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think and see
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want to know what Gary Vee DJ Khalid
Oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video